hello hi it's freezing in here yeah good
keeping with the theme I see right yeah
right
create alpine conditions yes nice room
yeah cuz your accolade so this film how
is it possible that two household names
I mean comedy legends at this point have
never met each other until making this
film how's that possible we're not sure
I know it's one of life's great
mysteries but but we met on this project
and and now we're forever joined at the
hip really what was it like meeting for
the first time well we were in we met to
discuss the script and we were in a
restaurant that had no other clientele
so strange it was all strange we were
just happy we didn't get food poisoning
cuz I'm not really sure why nobody else
was there I just remember Julie was
wearing a black leather jacket that is
correct and I was like oh what she wears
a cool black leather jacket yeah yeah
and we we had coffee and we were just
talking about the script and yeah and he
was very down-to-earth yeah and we got
along immediately it was really kind of
a miracle I told her my demands upfront
contractually
oh it's we just said well I'm not a
lawyer right
okay you should know this is how I like
to play ball hmm yeah so well done we
worked at all
yeah we did work it out for the most
part yeah I know that you had signed on
for this project for quite some time
yeah what was it about will that you
just thought he would be perfect to run
from an avalanche for this well I saw it
wasn't so much of that as it was that
first of all obviously I'm a big fan of
Will and his comedy but in fact I had
seen the work he didn't stranger than
fiction in which he really tackled a
pretty dramatic role and and I thought
he nailed it and so I and this movie has
it is a real mix of drama and comedy and
I thought okay well this guy can handle
it no problem yes you know not a lot of
people can in my view do but just sort
of straddle both genres yeah how about
that Wow
there's your cab it's a big deal I love
it
um can you both ski yes in real life yes
yeah okay and if an avalanche comes are
you running or would you protect your
family that's a question that we've all
been debating in the hallway okay yeah
what would you do yeah what's been the
consensus pens on the aged children I'm
protecting the adults I'll scream run
and then I'm going but if there are
adult children getting some real insight
yeah amazing and to help Canadians think
no I don't represent all I know that you
did a deal with Apple for the long term
will you and will collaborate again who
knows it's possible I it depends on how
he behaves on the rest of this interview
to be honest with you I don't know well
it is this interview alone or the rest
of the interviews
yeah so and to be honest I feel like
we've had a great interview so far it's
been okay it's been okay anyway let's go
to the next question
yes well Canada thanks you and goodbye
[Laughter]